hey guys i'm back with another tutorial
on hd tutorial on how to down well how
to get um high-res videos quickly using
missile firefox so what we're going to
do is open the firefox internet browser
and right now
i'm using my mac resolution but i'm
using a 1440 by 900. so we're going to
type that in and search
and
go to google images and search our
resolution and sure enough we get a ton
of cool wallpapers some pretty kick-ass
wallpapers that i want to use so i'll
click on this one
click full size image
and missile firefox built in has a set
as desktop background tool going on real
quick you right click it hopefully you
can see this because it's hd set it as
desktop background and you'll get a
little window popping up saying do you
want to make it the center
do you want it to be tile or do you want
to stretch now the preview didn't change
because this image is actually perfectly
fit to my desktop and that's how it
gives a little option for the background
color just in case it's smaller
and what we're going to do is set it as
desktop background and instantly you'll
notice i'll exit out here
voila it's my desktop background and
this is a pretty sweet background it
fits completely
and another thing is it's not going to
take a lot of time to load because it
fits my resolution perfectly it's not
too high res which would take longer to
load and wouldn't fit my screen because
i'd be stretching
so um let's go to personalize
and go to desktop background
and sure enough
there is if we want to always go back to
the windows wallpapers we can click here
and it'll load a bunch of the wallpapers
that came with the computer and i'll go
down to the widescreen ones and click
this one and
i'll be in this uh a built-in windows
wallpaper but should i ever want to
switch back
to that one i have i'll just right click
or a left click up here and say files
say
let's see it says users
app data roaming mozilla
and i'm sure it continues to say firefox
and program files if you click on this
you'll have your wallpaper here
simply left click it once and i think
when i hovered over it yeah there you go
um showed me specs about the actual
wallpaper so look
it's 4.9 megabytes and it fits perfectly
it's 1440x900
perfect
another thing how you how you know that
this image is actually the size of your
screen
if you type in your resolution
and hit enter of course and
if you actually are google searching
this
is that
that was odd
all right redo
open up firefox
and if you type in your resolution again
and you google image search this so the
images it'll say under every image i'm
sure you're what the exact resolution is
part of the blinking 1440 by 900 and
it'll say the size of it
1440 by 900.
44 to 900. some of them will be titled
something about 1440 by 900 but they
won't actually be of that resolution so
be wary of those
six thirty five by three ninety seven
that will not fit your wallpaper it is a
lot smaller also notice
so um that's how i get my wallpapers
that i change wallpapers all the time
that's how to get wallpapers quickly
using the missile firefox internet
browser so um i hope you liked this
tutorial if you did go ahead and
subscribe thanks for watching
you